l époque on y va pour empêcher un
massacre mais par ailleurs on renverse
le dictateur et tout le monde à ce
moment là n'est pas d'accord est ce que
là il ya est-ce que la gérance admettons
pour l'ingérence humanitaire qui
consiste à empêcher le massacre mais la
gérance qui consiste à renverser le
dictateur ce que personne ne nous avait
demandé
est ce que c'est mais pas ce qu'on n'a
pas franchi un pas la générale trinquant
oui c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous
reproche en particulier la russie et la
chine
puisque vous savez que la résolution
sous chapitre 7 qui avait été adoptée à
l'époque à la demande de la france
demandé d'intervenir mais que
l'abstention de la russie et de la chine
a été obtenue par ce que il était
compris qui aurait certaines limites et
ses limites ont été franchies ceux qui
depuis amène à une grosse difficulté
dans l'adoption des résolutions qu'on se
lâche et de conseil de sécurité donc je
suis d'accord avec vous on a
probablement été au delà de ce qui était
autorisé
beaucoup de pays africains nous le
reproche un président issoufou en
particulier l'a dit très clairement il a
dit moi on m'a jamais demandé mon avis
alors que ma frontière nord et est
proche et sur la frontière libyenne
donc beaucoup d'africains reproche le
fait qu'on ait renversé un dictateur
sanguinaire certes mais qui apportait
malgré tout une certaine stabilité dans
cette zone donc je pense que ça peut se
discuter effectivement et cette
résolution est peut-être allé trop loin
maintenant comme cela vient d'être dit
aujourd'hui il est plus facile de
regarder les choses comme ça moi j'ai
souvenir pour être allé à tripoli après
le départ de du président kadhafi
d'avoir vu un pays qui avait fait des
élections qui avaient fait une nouvelle
constitution et dont on pouvait penser
qu'il allait vers le chemin de la paix
il n'a pas été accompagnée du tout dans
cette période-là tout le monde l'a
laissé tomber et ensuite on est revenu
aux vieux démons qui sont de prendre les
armes pour essayer d'imposer sa loi
[Musique]